pixels movies are a veritable basket of
Easter eggs filled with running gags and
references to other Pixar properties
that only eagle-eyed fans might notice
cars 3 is no exception
and contains a truckload of new hidden
gems but I like a challenge
here's a look at some of the Easter eggs
you might have missed in the Cars
franchises third lap around the track a
1 1 3 it's a tradition for Pixar films
to contain at least one reference to
a113
the number of the classroom in which
many of its veterans including John
Lasseter and Brad Bird studied in at the
California Institute for the Arts
luckily the symbol wasn't too hard to
spot in Kosrae a113 shows up most
noticeably on the door of the office of
Rusty's owner and company CEO sterling @
he takes a meeting with his new racer
product Lightning McQueen the pizza
planets truck ever since it debuted in
Pixar's first feature film Toy Story the
Pizza Planet truck has popped up in most
of its films considering lightning
McQueen's car number 95 is a direct nod
to the year Toy Story was released it's
not too surprising that in cars 3 the
old pickup makes yet another appearance
the truck pops up this time maturing
that demolition derby race McQueen and
his trainer turned Protege Cruz Ramirez
participates in while undercover in the
mud truck scene it's open season in
terms of which types of vehicles can
participate in the crazy 8 run with the
last vehicle standing emerging as the
night's winner and for a brief moment
the Pizza Planet truck can be seen
giving it a go against the likes of
incognito McQueen Ramirez and a school
bus miss fretta whose name may be a wink
to Magic School Bus teacher miss Frizzle
I don't know the pixar bore much like
a113
for pixar luxo ball a yellow bouncy ball
with a blue stripe and a red star has
become a must for each of the studio's
films including cars 3 along with the
Pizza Planet truck the Pixar ball can be
seen in the demolition derby sequence
drawn on the hood of one car that
crashes into another Marez the Pizza
Planet truck was a dead giveaway thanks
to its rocket topper the Pixar ball is a
little trickier two spots in the
mudslinging crowd of
some familiar branding the car series is
filled with automobiles that are
sponsored by for corporations and there
are a ton of Easter eggs planted in
those brand names by and large for
example makes an appearance as a sponsor
of one of the early race cars in the
film and is seen on the sidelines as one
of McQueen's major races against rookie
sensation Jackson storm PNL Pixar fans
might recall it's a corporation that
made an appearance in wall-e and played
a big role in leaving the world in ruins
it's since appeared in subsequent
depicts topics including Toy Story 3 and
up Dinoco is another old brand has
continued to maintain its relevance in
the cars world as a sponsor of strip
weathers his nephew Cole weathers and
eventually newcomer speedster Ramirez
another brand that gets a nod as Triple
Dent gum which was first introduced in
inside-out Cinderella's pumpkin
Sterling's office isn't just a place
where a113 can be found the iconic image
of Cinderella's pumpkin carriage can
also be seen in the background of his
office although Cinderella is an ancient
property of pre Pixar Disney the film
has been referenced in subsequent house
of mouse properties before including The
Little Mermaid Coco Pixar's next
cinematic release Coco also gets a
couple of nods in cars 3 not only does
the name of the film appear to pop up in
the racetrack sidelines during a few
shots in the film but the town featured
in the movie is also showcased on a
training screen at the fancy new
Sterling Center when a racer is asked by
Ramirez to think of his hometown NASCAR
racers take a new name NASCAR fans
should have a field day figuring out
which of their tertiary characters in
the film represent the real-life racers
who voiced them among the industry
superstars who make brief audio cameos
as car characters in the film
Jeff Gordon reprising his car's - role
as Jeff covet Darrell Waltrip coming
back as darrell cartrip daniel Saurez
making his debut as daniel suarez Ryan
Blaney is Ryan inside Laney chase
Elliott's as Chase race alerts and Bubba
Wallace driver of the number six Disney
Pixar's Cars three Ford as Bubba
wheelhouse
gentlemen start your Mike
perhaps the most subtle NASCAR reference
though had more to do with a monkey than
a human driver Jaco Flaco is the storied
simian co-driver that helps Tim flock
win a race in the early 50s
his name was referenced by the disguised
Mac put on his trailer to trick races at
the drift track where McQueen and
Ramirez went to practice Paul Newman
resurrected perhaps one of the most a
bittersweet surprises in cars three is a
return of Doc Hudson a character
originally voiced by the late Paul
Newman his status as lightnings mentor
made a monumental impact on the racer
especially as lightning added more miles
to his odometer and started being edged
out by newer faster vehicles not only
was he brought back in spirit in
flashbacks to his scenes from cars but
he was also given new dialog during
those nostalgic moments
[Music]
according to Cars three producer Kevin
Rhea those sound bites came courtesy of
between takes cars audio that captured
Newman a real-life driving enthusiast
talking about racing just for fun
he told / film John Lasseter had left
all the tapes running on cars one so he
had all these hours of Paul talking
about everything and the love it was
about racing car talk for fans of the
NPR talk-show Car Talk the voices of Tom
Magliozzi who passed away in 2014 and
his brother ray have been fun additions
as rusty and dusty throughout the Cars
films they pay poignant tribute to their
old show while saying goodbye to McQueen
after selling rust-eze to Sterling with
the hopes of giving their prize to raise
her a better life by uttering the car
talk catchphrase don't drive like my
brother and don't drive like my brother
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]